A
THECTS TO QUEE
NEVEPMET
BRINO  THE
PRESIDENT ARRIVES INIDT FOTIN T
OR NUCLEAR WEAPONS IN UKRAINE.S.
HERE'SS UKRAINE SUCCEEDSN THE
BATTLEFI VLADIMIR PUTI
INORMING EMBED ANDD
AND I WONDERIDENT, WOULDM IF
TACTICAL NUCLEAR WEAPONS
>>
ITIL FACE OF WING SIWO
WO WHAT? BOU THINK WU IF
T ITE?E L
IN THE W THAN THEY
BEEN, INDEPENDENT TO THE EXTENT
OFHALLPOWOULOCCUR.
'SE THER
CO IN UKRAE
A ENSIVE HAS  TLIBERATED LARGE
COUNTRY THAT RUSSIA INVADED AND
CUPIED SIXON
THF TERRITIS
BINGOVERIES LIKE
E IN THE
VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY SAYSE OF
IAE BO THEY'VE FOUND SW REATIMIN
AS A LOO
SEC MUSIC BY IINNG PUTIN'S
SETBACKS SRRBLIC
ELECTED POLITICIANS, TOOTION B
NT
JA RUSSIAN RIGHTNGUT T H, ,
PEOPLE.ter: THAT FAHA
RUSSIAARG E SETBACKS, THATS FUE
LIBES OFUS
SOCIETY BUT ALSO
WELL.
>> YEAH.TUALLY PRO WAR ACTIVIEEL
E EARLY HAR GROUP OFE THL.
ANTIWAR PROTESTE IOW N FEBRUANES
B TOO E ANSEWOEFULLYER TROOPATE
CO CAUSE.
ER RAN
FIR  RESIGN.N, SHE TOLD
ME, ISEPRIVING RUSSIAN POOR,Y
ARE T .
THERS FACILITIES,
SUSSEALLY PRODUCE  ITUR THICH IU
WHAT IMPACT THAT LACK OF VI T
YOU SPEATO?
FE.L DEPRESSIVETMPH ANDRATION
>> Reporte INSISTS
O IILWITH THEUSNT.
OW HOME D ROT THENE SWAGGER OUT.
, N,DO LET'S SPEAK
WITH RETIREN
MIRYSTY CLARK.L CLARK,ORMM  I.CS
FOR BEING WITH US.HEARD MATTHEWT
E RISING ISS RITNG
YOUR SENSETHMEAN,
DOT N'
>> NO DOUB
EE THA
NOS IT.
THERE'S ALWAYS BEEN T OF
NABEE IT'S E STATE.
E IMPEACHED AND WN OUT OR.EVER
PROBANY
IT OOR A
THE LAST YEAR HE'S T
EXTRAORDINARASITCRATS RS
THEYLIS  GOING TBY SOMEBODY CLOE
AKRE T BA  IN TERMS OFUARDS,
EVERY' TWI
F IT WOULDEAT TO SEE HIM
COUR
A WOBBLE ID I THIN'S
GOING TO COME BACK AND TRYRE OUA
HE JIME RAMILITARY ASSISE.E GOI
MOMENTUM TT'
THUNARMORED VEHICLES. ERATIVE
ATVE GIV
THEYE ING A TREMENDOUS
NOT LIKE SOMETHING WE
PUTIN
TROU HS SEAPPENS.
THAT'S NOT IT.
A T
OG
ON ONE TRACK WE'
CONTINUE T
ASSTAND ONK,EHIND SCLIINO PUTINE
PEOP Y ATEONS, GET OUT
D 'T'RE
GOING TO INCREASE THRY
WE HAVE THMOIN A -ND THEY'RE GO
WITH US, WE HA THERTUNITS THIS
MILOSEVIC IN THECCEEDED WITH T
THERE'S  O FOR T
FORMAL, POWERFULOLE BEHIND THE
END WE SHOULD BE DOI
AGAINST
PRN IS WARNINGTO NOT EVEN THINK.
HRDAIRED THAT'S GOI
TO BE ONRRT.O. PUTINO
SOMETHIN AT THIS T?E D DO IT,
THEY'RE NS,THE UNITED
TREMENDOUS SHOCK
FESS G
NUCLEAR WEONWO -OTINAVE TO BECOM
--TICAL NUCLEAR WEAPON NOCIN BAT
AND WE KNOW WHAT I
WHAT WE UL
PRESIDT'TO THAT, BUT WE'VELOT OE
HE'S LOSING IN
THE EYES OF CHINA